hour one there is only one news story on
every website newspaper and tv screen
the flowers are blooming everywhere all
across the globe every country every
landmass the bitter cold of the
antarctic gives way to a glowing rainbow
of petals the sahara desert and death
valley become beacons of thriving
technicolor plant life the highest
mountains the lowest valleys the darkest
caves the flowers even burst free from
the concrete of cities as if reminding
us that really it was never our world we
were only borrowing it and today
our lease is up this is scp-001
object class unnecessary it was foretold
by tales from other dimensions a distant
future coming down the tracks towards us
and today the train has reached the
station nobody's reporting on how the
economy or the stock market is doing
today no point celebrity scandals have
faded away into nothingness greedy
businessmen lying politicians brutal
tyrants none of them are making the
headlines today the very last headlines
the world gone beautiful and what a
shame it takes the end of it all to make
us realize what really matters to us
that's right you're looking at the end
of the world but it's okay
don't panic take a deep breath in and
out it was bound to happen eventually so
no point worrying now even the
foundation knows that this just isn't
something they can stop so instead of
asking things like how can we prevent
this or do we have any final tricks up
our sleeve let's ask a different
question entirely what would you do if
you knew that you only had 24 hours
until all life on earth ends think hard
after all even if you never live to see
the flowers bloom a final day will still
come for you just as it does for us all
our six a d-class sits alone in the cell
when he sees the flowers growing out of
the ground normally he'd assume that
this meant he was in some kind of
foundation experiment but not today
everyone on earth had an innate sense
that the time is now a kind of gallows
calm spreads out over everyone and
everything it's over and that's okay we
all knew it was going to happen
eventually right he sighs and gives a
slight smile those flowers sure are
beautiful that's when he hears footsteps
outside his cell approaching a key
slides into his cell door and opens
there stands dr gears holding a bottle
of wine and two glasses anyone who knows
him might think he's been replaced by
some kind of shape-shifting anomaly or
had his mind taken over by a powerful
cognito hazard but no
it's him the famously cold dr charles
ogden gears dr gear says come on it's a
lovely day out there it'd be a terrible
waste to spend the whole thing cooped up
in here it'd feel like a trick on any
day but this the d-class nods and
follows the doctor out the normally oh
so stoic foundation senior researcher
pours himself in the d-class each a
glass of wine and asks what's your name
by the way i don't think i ever checked
the d-class replies that his name is
harold the two smile and chat as they
exit the now empty d-class containment
wing everyone else is outside already
researchers guards administrative staff
and d-classes all rubbing elbows
enjoying the beautiful sun on their last
day together elsewhere on site a flock
of scp-514 is released just as identical
flocks are being released from every
containment site all over the world
they've prepared it all for this very
day
scp-514 is a special breed of homing
pigeons created by the mana charitable
foundation which have the power to
suppress aggression for those within
their field of anomalous influence and
now millions of them are flying all over
the world after all there's no point
fighting on a day like this there is no
future left to secure people always told
them there would forever be hope until
the flowers bloomed no situation was
ever truly over until the world went
beautiful but in the absence of hope
there was something even more inviting
total absolute calm the site 19
personnel sit together and watch the
flowers bloom hour 12. all militaries
call a global ceasefire soldiers from
opposing sides hug and shake hands in
flowery fields that once seemed choked
by death and blood borders fade bitter
rivalries turn to dust korea unifies all
is quiet in the middle east gangsters
and drug cartels drop their weapons and
return home to their families and
friends as flocks of scp-514
fly above what good is all the blood
money in the world on a day like this
wardens walk cell to cell through all
the world's prisons granting people
their freedom again sometimes after
lifetimes of not having it they taste
the air again feel the sun on their face
they close their eyes drink it in and
walk among the flowers free men
locations of marshall carter and dark
limited close their doors and shutter
their windows worldwide for the first
time in as long as any of them can
remember they turned their signs too
closed they've earned a day off everyone
has the chaos insurgency rolls up their
plans and burns them they drop their
weapons and throw away their tactical
gear as they do so they can't help but
question themselves what was it all for
in the end what was any of it for all
the fighting in bloodshed and death we
did it day after day only to do it again
the next day what silly reasons we
killed and died for what silly reasons
indeed the global cult coalition
dismisses its staff thanking them for
their service and telling them to go
spend their last hours with the ones
they love like the foundation they
accept that this is the one true final
end no ritual to stop no monster to
fight no evil extra dimensional entity
to thwart just go outside and smell the
flowers while you still can the
serpent's hand are similar they decide
after decades fighting a losing battle
they'll spend their last day in the
wanderers library reading some of their
favorite volumes all these wonderful
stories now left for other earths to
read their own stories would be counted
among them in the end and they take
great comfort in that in a sense
everyone will live forever in the pages
of the books in the wanderers library
herman fuller's circus of the
disquieting releases all of its freaks
and clowns from their twisted grasp to
go and live out whatever small dreams
and tiny pleasures they could find over
their last hours they have no foundation
of fear anymore nobody minds their
strange appearances and odd behaviors
why would anyone waste such a beautiful
day judging others on the last day on
earth there's nothing left to prove
sarkicists dropped their ancient
flesh-bound tomes and acolytes of the
broken god put down their gilded blades
on the slopes of siberia the jungles of
peru and the most isolated beaches of
mexico twisted flesh finally touched
living metal in the spirit of husbandry
their eternal war is at its end in the
face of the blooming world they didn't
seem so different after all the agents
of the dr wondertainment corporation
predictably chose to spend their last
hours sitting around and playing with
toys together time well spent if you ask
us in a highly secretive location
perhaps the most heavily secured place
in the entire world the 13 members of
the legendary 05 council decide to just
sit and talk anyone who knows anything
about this secretive cabal can tell you
the 05 council has spent a considerable
portion of their very very long lives
trying to figure out ways to dodge and
cheat death but now facing a death they
can't dodge the same calm washing over
the rest of the world has finally
reached them too all they can really
think this time is well played reaper
well played as they chat about the kind
of inane casual things that they haven't
had time to discuss in years 05-3
suggests inviting the ethics committee
over to join nobody disagrees hour 16.
it isn't just the d-classes all sapient
and non-aggressive scps have been
released from containment free to spend
the last of their time as they wish tens
of thousands of anomalous individuals
are released from containment sites all
over the globe it'd be the greatest
victory that the serpent's hand could
ever ask for if they weren't all too
busy reading to notice
scp-105 iris thompson finally returns to
her parents the foundation had fed them
the lie that their daughter had died
many years before but as iris had a
tendency to do she was ready to work a
miracle her parents embrace her with
open arms they'll spend their last hours
together catching up on what's happened
since they parted ways and making up for
lost time they couldn't be happier
scp-1867 lord blackwood the fantastical
sea snail is delivered into a warm rock
pool near the site where he was being
contained there he might finally have
one more grand adventure before all is
said and done though afterward he may
not have the time to tell anyone about
it a terrible shame really because
nobody spins a yarn like lord blackwood
the non-aggressive little misters run
free mr fish eagerly returns to his
native boston massachusetts where he
enjoys one more lobster sandwich before
the end of the world mr headless decides
to go hat shopping because he wants to
look good for the apocalypse mr lost
finally settles down for the afternoon
deciding that just this once he's earned
himself a rest scp-28 cactus men returns
to edinburgh to spend his last days
picking up litter and helping old ladies
cross the street
scp-3663 the tunnel monster walks the
streets of his hometown searching for an
old friend hoping to reunite before it
all ends
scp-073-kane decides to take a walk
outside for the first time in thousands
of years he can't help but smile as the
bright colorful life beneath his feet is
growing faster than his presence can
kill it what a truly beautiful day
knowing that there's no longer time for
colts to form and bother him
scp-2662 cthulhu decides to take a break
from his intense minecraft session and
go take a walk outside it feels so good
to have the sun on his tentacles once
more and to feel the lush green grass
under his suction cups he shakes his
head thinking once again about the
irritating cults that had been pestering
him for decades what kind of idiot would
want him to destroy a world like this
scp-343 also known as god sighs and
looks over all his creation for what he
knows to be the last time his mouth
curls into a smile as he thinks well we
had a pretty good run still in a cell
scp-049 the plague doctor puts his feet
up and decides to relax the pestilence
will soon be taken care of on some
animalistic level below thought below
even instinct
scp-096 feels grateful that no gaze will
ever fall upon it again somewhere
fizzling in a vat of acid within a
highly secure containment chamber
scp-682 is feeling for the first time in
its hellish existence a sense of
profound relief the pain the hate the
rage the constant termination attempts
it'd all be over soon hour 23 people
gather in the streets they laugh and
dance and sing as the moon shines fat
and white far above deep in their hearts
they quietly contemplate the end of all
of this but why worry why spoil the fun
there's no future left to worry about
strangers become as close as family in
the end human or otherwise anomalous or
non-anomalous chaos insurgency agents
have last suppers with ex-serpents hands
and goc operatives there is no hate left
no violence no malice no cruelty the
greatest tragedy in all of this is that
it took the ultimate end to bring it out
in people but why worry why worry
seconds pass then minutes the world
buzzes it hums trillions of creatures
doing everything they'd wanted even
though it won't last in the face of the
true end the world has never been more
alive hour 24
silence forever and ever and ever good
night we'll end this video the way it
began by putting a question to you how
would you spend your last 24 hours on
earth let us know down in the comments
because it'll happen to all of us
eventually now go check out scp-001
which is the real zero zero one and
scp-001
oroboro cycle the full story compilation
for more journeys into the surprising
and varied world of scp-001